well well well it's been a while since
i've updated uh ancient archer my little
game engine i'm working on so i figured
i'd do a video on it because
well the repos private so nobody really
knows what's going on except for me
unless i actually uh make a video and
tell you guys so
figured i'd do that of course if you do
want access to it you can you can get
that by signing up on patreon but
yeah i don't think i'm just gonna leave
it public anymore uh main reason well
i
had it public for like i don't know its
entire life cycle for like four or five
years and there was not a single bit of
help from the public so
i'm already on my own on it there's no
real difference to me if i make it
private this is kind of the reality of
most developers we just have to work on
things alone even if you try to get help
you're not going to get it so i just
decided you know i'm just going to do
this because for the most part if
anyone's looking at it they're probably
just trying to catch up
and steal from it anyway so i'll just
make it all private and if you want to
steal from it you know you got to pay
money huh i say that all tongue in cheek
so hopefully no one's too offended by
that but if you are
i don't really care but yeah i'm just
going through and uh marking a bunch of
changes doing a few pull requests i
fixed a lot of stuff in
a recent update i've been adding a lot
of tests
and you know i've been talking about
tests a lot on my channel recently but
you know one of the big things about
these tests is
man i should have done this so long ago
like i've had so many
outstanding bugs and accidentally
introduced so many bugs when adding in
new things
specifically because i didn't have tests
so i didn't realize that when i was
adding in some things i was breaking
others but now that i have tests i'm
able to actually
fix things and make sure i'm not
breaking other things
and it's been amazing so just kind of
working up a list of these latest
changes from my building test branch and
there were a lot fixed memory leaks
added some switching skybox
functionality
there were a few bugs in the cursor
settings i
fixed a lot of texture loading stuff
there were some issues where
alpha non-alpha grayscale wasn't quite
working as intended i fixed some window
resizing issues
and improve the
model loading efficiency
but just kind of making a little
uh bullet point of all the main things
here that is going to the dev branch on
ancient archer 2
private so
that's kind of where i'm at right now
and i'm just you know i'll run through
some of the tests
here i guess you know i got eight of
them right now
and i also did another big thing
that was pretty important
i basically made a
little program
within the project called download test
resources
because it's a bunch of models sounds
and textures
and i don't want them to be part of the
repo because they make the repo huge
their model files and stuff there's a
lot of megabytes of just stuff
so i put them all on a hosted site and
now you have to run this download test
resources
before you run any tests because it goes
and downloads all of them
uh for you
uh so yeah that's where that is it just
downloads these runtime files and puts
them in this runtime files folder so now
they're no longer part of the repo
they're posted separately
and i basically just use
some quick
curl action to download those
and do the thing
but yeah i actually wrote most of this
on stream one day so maybe some of you
actually saw it if
you were following my stream then
you probably did
i don't know if the vod's still up there
or not but
anyway
yeah let's run a few of these tests uh
so i've got the test suite here i'll
just put it over here for a moment
and uh yeah i'll show you kind of where
it's at and some of the issues so let's
run
let's run the skybox one this one's kind
of cool so basically any feature that
gets added or changed
i want to make sure there's an
associated test
okay so here's the skybox test you can
switch to here's a day one it's got a
camera that kind of spins in a circle
and wobbles up and down there's the
night one
here's a cave one
so yeah just basically making sure all
the textures or yeah the cube map
textures work for these these are all
cube map versions
for now and there's a little toggle full
screen button makes obs go black for a
second but it should load back up there
we go
so you do that too
and then you just got to click yes to
say it worked
now let's look at the models i'm still
there's still a lot of
render graph work
to do so that's kind of where i am now
as i'm uh back to the render graph which
i always come back to
here and there
but now with testing it should be a lot
easier to sort it out in the long term
some fly controls here or some first
person block controls added in
and there's a little spinning cube with
uh
no textures so that's the default color
right now if you don't texture things
can be changed on the fly maybe i'll
even put that as a setting in the engine
but as you can see in general the
texture loads okay this guy looks pretty
fine
he doesn't move or anything but you can
see there's a light
so let's kind of also test the lighting
i can move the light around
no great visual of where the light is
currently
uh other than you can tell kind of where
he's getting
shaded i also don't have shadows in you
yet i've played around with shadows but
they're definitely not ready i've
actually got some other stuff i want to
work out first all right let's look at
skeletal animation we want to make sure
those work
as well so we can run that test
and uh yeah here's a zombie that's doing
a little punching so we'll just walk up
to him
he is lit so i do have lighting on
animated textures working okay
although
well there's a few things about it
but uh it's kind of a lot to explain
um
so
yeah i'm not gonna try to explain it all
but basically
the lighting on
animated models is a lot different
because depending on where they're
currently at
you might have to do the lighting
different you know they'd be the lights
hitting them different but i don't it's
not that noticeable though so it's not
super critical but if i'm going for
perfection i'd want to sort that out but
it looks a little complicated here's a
model mashup just a bunch of different
models loaded at once including animated
and non-animated
and we'll see there is they're huge i've
got a guy over there that's just walking
and the cube just chilling
but yeah this seems to work okay loading
multiple it's a little slow
definitely needs some optimizations
uh but mainly i just want to get it all
working first and then i'll optimize
later now here's some sound effects so
go ahead and play those just make sure
sound effects all work okay
and uh yeah i just got some sound
effects loaded up it only supports og
and wave and well just not mp3 basically
that's probably really loud
let me just turn that down a little bit
flashlight gunshot
metal gear solid sound all right so yeah
sounds seem to work okay
um and stencil outlining this is the
latest test i added and i you know i
actually thought stenciling was good
until i made this test so just another
important thing as you can see
the stenciling goes behind that model
which is not supposed to do
like if you have a model stand alone it
looks fine but as you can see the bottom
of that stencil
is not correct it's like in the
the floor it's not it's supposed to be
in front of that floor
so that's not right so i got something
with a render graph i've got something
ordered wrong it's the same with this
guy you can see a little gray outline
around him but once it gets to the floor
you can see it's
no longer there so there's a little bug
in that
and yeah so stenciling is not perfect i
gotta analyze what i'm doing in the
wrong order there
it seems to be okay on its own but as
soon as you start throwing in other
models it doesn't
yeah so it's probably just one thing in
the wrong order
that's the way it goes
and that's where it's at right now
so yeah just uh
i didn't really plan all this video out
so hopefully you find it interesting i
basically just was doing this for the
day and
then i decided to hit record and talk
about it for a second so i hope you
enjoy the video
i'll see you guys in the next one and uh
let me know if you have any questions
down below feel free to leave a comment
it does help out the channel leave a
like
and subscribe for more code stuff
let me know what you want to see let me
know if you have any insights
and uh last but not least let me know if
you want to help out with this kind of
stuff because i'm always looking
for additional help if anyone wants to
do that
and i'll see in the next one peace